all of us just need to have a bigger
conversation about the beauty standards
that we're setting I don't want my
daughter to do the things I did I wish
I'd never touched anything to begin with
Kylie Jenner going there about her
cosmetic work I know people say things
all the time I don't even know where we
left off a new season of the Kardashians
picks up with the beauty mogul's
surprising comments I see those sides
yeah I see both sides a sneak peek at
season three teasing plenty of drama
worth tuning in for I'm really good at
being calm when there's turbulence
but this has been a whirlwind of a year
Kylie's admission promises to be an
emotional moment all of us just need to
have a bigger conversation about the
beauty standards that we're setting as
it follows years of backlash against the
famous family with critics taking aim at
their passion and sometimes obsession
with looking good
I don't want my daughter to do the
things I did I wish I'd never touched
anything to begin with and it's a topic
that's clearly been weighing on Kylie
just last week she opened up to a
homegirls magazine explaining that a big
misconception about her is that she's
had so much surgery on her face and that
she's an insecure person deep down like
I would love my true fans to know like
all my personal stuff yeah I love full
lips and wanted full lips but growing up
I was always the most confident person
in the room as for what Kylie calls that
lip insecurity thing she says she fixed
it with filler and it was the best thing
she's ever done I think my love for
makeup started with my insecurity with
my lips so it's not totally in line with
what she says in the new trailer I wish
I never touched anything to begin with
but it does Echo her comments on the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians reunion
in 2021. I had really small lips and I
didn't ever think about it and until I
had one of my first kisses and a guy
said to me oh my God you're such a good
kisser we have such small lips or
something like that oh and then from
then from then on I felt
unkissable and then I got an obsession
with makeup because I would over line my
lips and it just made me feel confident
I love it the obsession blowing up into
a billion dollar brand Kylie Cosmetics
she made her own money for over a decade
she put it in the bank she saved every
nickel and then when she decided on what
she wanted to do she spent her money on
a venture that could have gone south or
north and it did really well back in the
max profile Kylie says that becoming a
mom changed her approach to Beauty my
daughter looks like me I get to see my
beauty in her and it's made me love
myself more I don't want my daughter to
do the things I did I wish I'd never
touched anything to begin with as for
how Kylie's fan reacts we're hoping to
see this combo in full when the show
returns May 25th I just won't think
everything's gonna be okay know how to
be there for each other
[Music]
thank you